[Musik]
[Applaus]
24 august 2017 auf dem militärflughafen
linz hörsching 52 militär musikerinnen
und musiker der militärmusik
niederösterreich starten ihre reise mit
der hercules c-130 ziel ist dass
spektakuläres pascal tower festival in
moskau
[Musik]
gemeinsam mit militärkapellen aus 14
nationen und über 1400 musikern werden
sie an neun abenden am roten platz in
moskau teil einer gewaltigen musikshow
sein
täglich wird mehr als 8000 zuschauer
erwartet
[Musik]
der kapellmeister oberst leuten und
adolf obendrauf ist stolz mit seiner
kapelle österreich in moskau
repräsentieren zu dürfen
unsere repräsentations geschichten und
musikalischen auftritte beschränken sich
eigentlich auf das bundesland
niederösterreich bisher vorbei wenige
festivals in österreich aber dass wir
jetzt auch österreich im ausland und vor
allem in moskau vertreten dürfen dass
eine besondere ehre und das macht uns
natürlich auch stolz
die show die zehnminütige show ist
abgestimmt auf das gastgeberland in
unserem falle haben wir einen russischen
marsch drinnen beziehungsweise die
russische marge fantasie von strauß und
auch was nicht fehlen darf ist natürlich
österreichische musik
[Musik]
die teilnahme an einen musik festival
dieser größe verlangt natürlich auch
nach einer intensiven vorbereitung
wir haben schon märz begonnen mit
exerziert technischen grundlagen und
sondern immer weiter ins detail junger
bis man die show weiter verändert haben
dass sie für moskau tauglich war erste
generalprobe muster oberwart ist mit der
musik festival im juni kann als wenn man
als stabführer in riesengroßen stadion
einmarschiert dann für die mir
persönlich nicht als erster unter vielen
sondern eher als gleicher unter gleichen
weil collins und großem orchester wie
bei der militärmusik niederösterreich
ist es ganz wichtig dass jeder am
gleichen strang ziehen dass anna
fruchtigkeit zur richtigen zeit wo alle
energien
und da ist jeder einzelne wichtig da ist
nicht an besser ist wieder andere
sondern stärkt ist nur so stark wie das
schwächste ist und das stärkte
gemeinschaft und dafür braucht es immer
volle leistungsbereitschaft
[Musik]
das siegen bleibt jedoch wenig zeit
auch abseits vom festival geben die
musiker einen einblick in die
österreichische musik kultur
[Musik]
die stimmung ist sehr gut
dass wir füreinander gespielt also james
essen oder klassische sachen
ich glaube es gibt überhaupt keine
bindung
[Musik]
die stimmung ist großartig
gibt es dafür 270 fester aber das
eigentlich dem musikfest in dieser größe
ist natürlich wahnsinn und für einen
jungen rekruten vierten ausbildungswoche
ist natürlich eine große ehre so damit
spielen darf damit existieren daten es
ist wirklich kaum zu beschreiben wie
unglaublich das ist
[Musik]
in größeren unternehmen
es ist irgendwie schreibe ich es macht
immer wieder viel spaß und das ist
eigentlich das schönste job darin
nach den vielen proben zusätzlich
engagiert und das ist immer das ist
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass man jemals im
leben sonst die möglichkeit hätte zehn
mal ihren roten platz aufzumarschieren
solche festivals als aktiver als aktiver
zu absolvieren das glaube ich geht sonst
nirgends vor allem nicht vor so einem
großen publikum denn der letzte konzert
abend wird auch vom russischen fernsehen
übertragen geschätzte zuschauer zeit 40
millionen also ein internationalen
festival für mich persönlich immer ans
mit nämlich den horizont erweitern und
neue stücke kennen zu lernen und was für
mich ganz wichtig ist eigentlich dass
ihr
alle sind ort sein und ist die einzige
veranstaltung ist die ihn kennen wo sie
dort in unterschiedlichen nationen
friedlich miteinander umgehen
friedlich miteinander kommunizieren
obwohl sie oft nicht einmal die gleiche
sprache sprechen beziehungsweise über
endlich
[Musik]